bienvenue sur Télématin nous sommes le
mercredi 6 septembre déjà bientôt les
vacances
j'aimerais des petits bateaux là
[Musique]
sur 5 et déclarent vivre à découvert 3%
de plus que l'an passé 32% n'ont pas les
moyens de manger sainement trois fois
par jour pour remplir leur trésorerie
beaucoup on recourt au crédit
renouvelable d'un montant de moins de
3000 euros en général ces crédits ont
des taux d'intérêt très élevés jusqu'à
20% le risque le surendettement un tiers
des familles rencontres des difficultés
pour pratiquer une activité sportive ou
de loisir pour leurs enfants ou pour les
membres adultes de la famille un quart
de ces mêmes familles doit se passer de
mutuelle au-delà ils sont 45% chez les
personnes interrogées 45% rencontré des
difficultés financières pour payer
certains actes médicaux mal remboursés
par la sécu ou contre 39% en 2022 donc
on voit que la situation s'aggrave
nettement des nouvelles rassurantes de
Mathieu Kassovitz après son accident de
moto dimanche
tous ceux qui m'ont appelé qui m'ont
envoyé des messages de soutien
merci beaucoup je savais pas que j'avais
autant d'amis ça fait plaisir
j'ai fait une chute de moto seulement je
me suis pété le fémur et la cheville et
voilà je suis en rééducation 60 % des
Français estiment qu'au cours des trois
dernières années leur pouvoir d'achat a
diminué ils sont 34 % à considérer que
le revenu leur permettent juste de
boucler leur budget et 18%, tu l'as dit
10 donc vivre à découvert ces trois
points de plus qu'en 2022 la hausse des
prix de l'alimentation et de l'énergie à
contraint de plus en plus de français à
solliciter les associations par rapport
à l'allée derrière on est à + 37 % tout
ça coupait avec l'inflation il y a un
effet de cisaille pour les restos qui
font que c'est difficile l'association
fondée il y a près de 40 ans par Coluche
appelle à l'aide victime de la hausse de
ses coups de fonctionnement elle risque
de mettre la clé sous la porte je vous
le dis à la maison si vous avez des
rêves c'est pas une question d'âge c'est
une question de rencontre de moments
accrochez-vous et demain vous serez
surpris parce que les choses se
réalisent un million 300000
bénéficiaires les restos du camp ont
déjà accueilli un million 300000
personnes depuis le début de cette année
début 2023 contre un million 100000 au
total l'an passé donc plus en huit mois
que sur toute l'année 2022 un chiffre
record depuis la création des Restos du
cœur en 85 par Coluche selon l'inrae
l'Institut national de la recherche
agronomique 8 millions de personnes dans
notre pays sont en situation
d'insécurité alimentaire soyez plus
heureux donc démissionné si vous avez
envie un démissionner démissionné le
nouveau slogan Télématin
pas d'autres mots donc
écoutez ce qui se passe
on n'hésitera pas et ils nous ont juste
dans notre histoire
ça fait 24 ans qu'on est là il y a pas
de souci attaquer mon souci si vous
estivez quand vous êtes diffamé la
rancune est quelque chose qui n'existe
pas pour moi je n'ai ni aucune
niamertume vous savez pourquoi parce que
je suis un bagarreur et les bagarreurs
et gardent rien en eux-mêmes
[Musique]
mais si vous faites un livre
si c'est pour faire de la guimauve
achetez-vous une confiserie pas une
librairie nous on a dit tout ce que nous
a raconté cette dame on a même des
preuves vous
allez bien juridique que vous avez
traité cette femme par texto ou par
téléphone Hervé rappelez-nous ce qu'a
dit monsieur
a dit qu'elle était conne comme est-ce
que vous le confirmez monsieur
excusez-moi je me suis emporté
il faut que vous sachiez que sur les 14
dernières années tous mes comptes seule
ma femme seule mes enfants seuls ma mère
ont été faits laserisé et qui dit
l'ordonnance de renvoi il n'y a aucun
soupçon d'enrichissement personnel la
part de Sarkozy c'est vrai ou c'est pas
vrai
vous me faites penser à Sarkozy vous
attendez attendez que ça fasse mal avant
de répondre gigantesque tricherie au
marathon de Mexico 11.000 coureurs sur
les 30 000 inscrits devraient être
disqualifiés pour avoir utilisé des
véhicules personnels ou des transports
en commun une attitude anti sportive
dénoncée dans un communiqué officiel un
tiers des participants n'a donc pas
couru les 42 km 195 de la course et a
été trahie par la puce électronique
portée par chaque coureur parmi les
mises en cause certains affirment que
c'est la puce qui n'a pas bien
fonctionné canicule incendie inondation
les trois derniers mois donne le tournis
partout sur la planète l'humanité vit le
changement climatique et son lot de
catastrophes naturelles c'est la
première fois de ma vie que je vois une
inondation aussi effrayante ce qui me
choque le plus
tout perdu en quelques secondes
en Inde une chaleur inédite le mois
d'août le plus chaud et sec depuis le
début des relevés il y a plus d'un
siècle j'essaye d'être écolo le plus
possible mais vous n'arrête pas
l'impression de nous emmerder quand même
parce qu'on représente 1% de la
population de pollution dans le monde 1%
et vous dites faut bouger faut faire des
trucs est-ce que la France ne bouge pas
pour l'écologie on nous dit d'acheter
des voitures électriques de merde qui
tombent en panne toutes les deux minutes
ça vaut 40 000 euros tu habites au 14e
étage faut une prise pour aller la
brancher en bas comment tu vas faire
c'est pas la pression de faire chier du
monde un petit peu autre phénomène
extrêmement Chine des inondations les
pires depuis 140 ans à Pékin là encore
une conséquence du réchauffement
planétaire des océans plus chauds c'est
plus de vapeur d'eau qui remonte dans
l'atmosphère pour retomber en pluie le
secrétaire général de l'ONU s'alarme de
ce terrible bilan
l'effondrement climatique a commencé
notre climat implose plus vite que nous
ne pouvons y faire face le plastique
l'emballage on fait plein de trucs on
taxe les Français
parce qu'il est trop lourd à la raison
ta faute tu achètes une autre voiture et
donc s'il y avait rien de fait s'il y
avait rien de fait je serai là en train
de vous dire que vous avez raison
[Musique]
[Rires]
fantastique regardez ça se passe aux
États-Unis en Californie il s'agit bien
d'une chèvre que vous voyez et bien elle
s'apprête à donner une leçon à faire du
surf regarder cette piste mobile peace
mobile en tout cas c'est le petit nom
voilà
la chèvre a l'air quand même assez
tranquille
[Rires]
en commentaire